[Musique]
grosse conne las vegas est bien due soit
l'europe
ça fait plaisir de faire des gros mots
non pourquoi parce que jeunes femmes
reçoivent débat sur téva étape haletante
moment quand une amie et fenêtres ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire que c'est
pas bien de regarder comment oui mais tu
es mon dire quand même
ouais pourquoi ils étaient contents
aujourd'hui d'en dire là ouais ça t'a
pas gêné de dire devant les instituteurs
n'ont tué andis venteux non mais vous
avez peur dans 10 à vous avez peur et
pourquoi tu as peur de dire des gros
mots
et si c'était pas interdit l'agent dire
on ne dit pas de gros mots parce que les
gros mots c'est mal polis qu'est ce que
ça signifie
il ya des conventions sociales il y a
une façon de se comporter bon et
l'enfant doit apprendre quelles sont les
règles de la société et quelles sont les
règles dans le milieu social dans lequel
il se trouve qui taperait d'ailleurs à
ne pas être d'accord mais il doit les
connaître exactement comme un adulte qui
connaît une langue connaît les gros mots
de cette langue apprendre une langue
étrangère sans apprendre les gros mots
de cette langue étrangère c'est ne pas
connaître la langue étrangère la liberté
de l'adulte comme celle de l'enfant elle
doit s'exercer dans la connaissance de
ce que représente cette langue aussi
bien au niveau des mots mais groupe ti
bien des gros mots et après il peut
faire un choix
madame si vous êtes des gros mots oui
bon coup lesquels par exemple oh le
[ __ ]
et c'est en direction de qui
généralement des hommes particulièrement
on voit de vous exprimer en voiture la
maison c'est gros c'est est-ce que vous
avez l'impression que les jeunes disent
plus de gros mots que les plus âgés non
non les plus âgés sont aussi grossier
qu'est ce que les filles disent attendre
mauvais garçon absolument aussi qu'est
ce que vous en pensez
tu peux le dire vraiment de voir une
grosse je pense baird par exemple ou
bien
e
ça fait chier si vous êtes chauffeur de
taxi est ce que vous dites beaucoup de
gros mots en voiture oui ça m'arrive
assez souvent ce qui est dans le métier
que j'ai fait est là on savait un peu
plus par le temps on est énervé alors
qu'elle elle jure ans qui revient le
plus souvent possible le plus souvent
votre bouche sale con et enfin des mots
comme ça quoi la voiture c'était une
arme de guerre
il ya de près de 500 morts par week-end
sur les routes les gens vivent à leur
façon une guerre qui fait treize à
quatorze mille morts par an etc
je crois que les gros mots dans la
voiture c'est une façon de dédramatiser
la mort qui est toujours à proximité pas
très loin et c'est d'ailleurs je crois
que c'est peut-être ça la vraie
définition des gros mots si ce sont des
gros mots c'est parce que ce sont des
mots très important on pourrait dire
qu'est ce que ce serait le contraire de
gros est ce que ces maigres petits les
gros mots c'est peut-être les mots les
plus importants alors je crois que le
débat n'est absolument pas de savoir
s'il faut empêcher les enfants de dire
des gros mots s'il faut leur interdire
s'il faut leur permettre je crois que
les gros mots sont certainement les plus
gros mot de notre langue mais qu'ils
sont vitaux négligent actuellement vers
une école où nous allons rencontrer des
enfants avec lui nous allons parler des
gros mots est-ce que c'est à l'école que
les enfants apprennent leur premier gros
mots et les dix balles et par on
voudrait bien croire que c'est à l'école
pour ce pour se déculpabiliser de ça
mais en fait les enfants apprennent les
gros mots dans l'univers adulte qui leur
est familier c'est à dire le plus
souvent la famille le père est le
premier gros mots c'est à quel âge oh je
crois que le premier gros mot universel
c'est caca boudin que tous les enfants
disent que soit leur classe aussi
indiqué lin aubin à l'époque où la merde
les intéresse c'est à dire vers un an et
demi deux ans quand ils deviennent
propre quand ils s'aperçoivent quand 200
d'entre eux ils acquièrent
une forme de pouvoir de chantage sur les
parents vous gérez caca boudin à kaka
crowther et qu'est-ce qui vous appelle
micro il ya d'autres choses qui vous
disent mais d'autres personnes
on avait déjà entendu comme ça titus
kherici plus que j'ai dessiné toi tu a
dessiné la merde il a pas mal tangué en
tête lundi pour toi pourquoi est ce que
les enfants non pas devant les parents
ça dépend de la permissivité de la
famille mais on s'aperçoit que des
enfants dont on croit qu'ils ne disent
pas gros mots en fête se cachent de
leurs parents pour en dire contre eux
j'ai l'impression que l'interdît
permettait justement le défoulement no
way c'est ce qu'on dit à travers
l'interdît et le travail de la
transgression l'enfant va se faire un
monde par le par le long détour du
fantasme mais moi je crois que c'est ça
permet à les attitudes éducatives les
plus répressives et finalement je fais
c'est contre ça
parce que des fois j'ai un pote faire
des bêtises
alors tu te punit toi-même patineront à
qu'est ce que tu me dire tu ne dis merde
ou 70 ans du ca c'est mon papa parce que
à chaque fois on savait qu'il ya un peu
de bien des gros mots sans blague alors
vas-y qu'est ce qu'il dit dans sa
voiture merde espèce de colas et c'était
à te dis commune jamais kaunas moi tu
déjà mâconnaise c'est quoi le connais je
sais pas c'est les filles qui apprennent
les groupements garçons et toi ou tu les
as appris quelques mots qui tend à
ventes mais est un plus gros mots craque
encore plus gros aupic perd gros pépère
gros pétard fois lui est encore plus
gros que les verts fallu et aime bien
dire des mots notre nom pourquoi parce
que parce que c' it napoli qui te dit
que c'était mal poli mois il parce que
tu es aussi comment tu veux parce que
souvenez de la perdre
[Musique]
c'est lui freine torah
tout le monde est à perdre les le l'état
des châteaux et les hyènes vantant durée
du mauvais temps vous expliquez vous le
fait que vos chansons et beaucoup de
succès auprès des enfants est ce que
c'est pour eux l'occasion de prononcer
des mots interdits par les parents pâtes
oui mais oui moi je suis une espèce aval
vous avez des lardons moi je disais je
fais un peu le facteur entrer les
enfants et les parents
1 c'est à dire que je rentre chez eux
par la télévision par la radio et serra
et quand je chante le printemps le zizi
estelle par exemple bon si je dis que je
bande pour elle c'est un mot qui en
général pour les lardons ils doivent
s'employer
si c'est moi qui le dit et que les
parents sont là il dit bon bah tu vois
il l'a dit et si à ce moment là les
parents saint-élie gens il explique ce
sont des mots poétiques
oui parce que c'est avant tout la poésie
de du contact direct de la rue du
langage spontané de la vérité je vous
dire et rien de tel que le démystifier
quelque chose pour en faire passer le
goût immédiat à quelqu'un
[Musique]
les enfants rient souvent quand ils
entendent les gros mots est ce que c'est
vraiment un aspect comique qu'est ce qui
provoque si je vous dis à mon avis ce
qui provoque le rire des mouflets c'est
une extraordinaire jouissance intérieur
qu'ils ont de d'enfreindre la chose
défendu ils jubilent d'avancé et je l'
ai vu je ne sais combien de fois sur le
sur le visage des enfants
cette espèce de halal alors papa maman
si j'avais eu faisant traduire ce truc
c'est pas vrai c'est pas possible tu te
rends compte qu'on vient de dire là mais
c'est le summum de la chose défendu et
je crois que ça l'effet cathedra fière
d'avoir gagné
chris espace devienne sa fille qui vit à
ma part en montagne à la mer de yale est
pas passé les mac os fait la même taille
et la coop ya le marbre le temps
[Musique]